my talk at the table I'm very excited
about this it comes from Robert De Niro
who recently revealed that he's a dad
again so we were with him on Saturday I
was interviewing him and Sebastian
Maniscalco about their upcoming movie
It's called about my father wow it's
inspired by Salvo Maniscalco who is
Sebastian's dad who also joined us in
the conversation so the movie has a
scene about kids being embarrassed by
their parents and I asked Robert De Niro
if this was something he could relate to
I was wondering Bob if any of your kids
ever told you know Dad you're
embarrassing oh yeah all the time
are they aware that you're Robert De
Niro they don't care
oh yeah no that's sure
so what didn't come up during our
interview is that De Niro who's 79 has a
newborn so I said we were with him on
Saturday that news was released on
Monday so I called him yesterday I said
don't you think Mr De Niro you could
have just mentioned that in passing that
you have this baby he goes well he said
I actually thought about it but we were
discussing the movie and I didn't want
to take anything away from the movie I
just didn't want to do that and it
didn't come up I said but why would I
ask if you have a baby but he was doing
interviews and the reporter said to him
you know you have six children and he
said no I have seven because he said in
that moment he didn't want to deny this
baby I don't think he's I know he's not
a shady guy he wasn't trying to dodge it
he's just living his life he's very
private but when when it was phrased
that way and I said well how should I
phrase it I thought the opening was have
any of your children embarrassed you
anyway so I said could I please please
please break the news about what kind of
baby is it what's the baby's name how
did this come about and he said there
first there was dead silence and he went
okay so this is not an exclusive gal
we're about to this is a bona fide
exclusive okay I present to you the
national TV debut of Gia Virginia chin
De Niro
oh wow six ounces when she was born on
April 6th how cute is this baby Robert
De Niro and his partner that's Tiffany
Chen are over the moon about this little
girl now this is the thing Robert De
Niro has six and now seven children his
oldest is in the early 50s he now has
this little baby and I said did you want
a baby he goes yes this baby is planned
they both wanted this baby they're over
the moon she was brought here by love so
he is very psyched and very excited
about it our full interview by the way
will air on Tuesday May 23rd here on CBS
mornings and it's about the movie about
my father Sebastian Maniscalco and his
dad which is also very hilarious and and
Bob plays Sebastian's Daddy I just would
want to be a fly in the wall when you
learned the news that he had a baby you
should have seen me I called and said uh
Stan who's Robert's agent Sam don't you
think he goes Gail listen you didn't
want anybody to know well it's just to
come full circle earlier Gail said
that's one of the cutest babies in the
world I think that is accurate
Virginia is his mom's name and of course
her name they're going to call her Gia I
love it she is one of his she's adorable